today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
saying the quiet part out loud has been
sort of a theme of the trump
administration
and a huge cause of the constant
self-inflicted damage that donald trump
has done to himself has come from
saying things out loud or tweeting
things that he would probably be better
off keeping
to himself and it has unfortunately
happened again and in conjunction with
the release of his new book called
rage investigative journalist bob
woodward has released
audio of conversations that he had
with donald trump during which a lot of
things happen
but making huge headlines is donald
trump admitting
that he publicly was not telling the
truth about coronavirus as early as
february
for political reasons now there's debate
as to whether they are good political
reasons or bad political reasons i would
argue it doesn't matter that donald
trump was deceiving the public
and it wasn't a matter of national
security it was donald trump
wanting it to appear as though he had
things under control when he did not
let's go first to the clip and then we
will discuss it donald trump admitting
to bob woodward
that at the time february 7th his belief
about coronavirus was that it was very
serious even
airborne although publicly even for
months after this
donald trump never acknowledged
coronavirus being as dangerous as he
admits
in this clip now it's turning out it's
not just old people bob
just today and yesterday some startling
facts came out it's not just
old older people to plenty of young
people so
what's going on give me an a a moment of
talking to somebody
going through this with faushi or
somebody
who kind of uh it caused a
pivot in your mind because it's clear
just from
what's in on the public record that you
went through
a pivot on this to oh my god the gravity
is uh almost inexplicable
and unexplainable well i think bob
really to be honest with you sure i want
you to i wanted to
uh i wanted to always play it down i
still like playing it down
yes because i don't want to create a
panic so there it is it's plain as day
now what is the response going to be
i'll tell you what it is it's not going
to be that the audio tapes have been
doctored because they clearly have not
the argument is going to be not wanting
people to panic
is something good that donald trump does
and it's something that he
has done in general during his
presidency of course it is not true
when it comes to the immigrant caravan
donald trump's strategy was
create as much panic as possible make
people think things are as dangerous as
possible even when they are not
when it comes to joe biden's america
the strategy is we want people to panic
because it's politically advantageous so
there are people i don't
know that they're all bad faith actors
but they certainly are making nonsense
arguments who are saying
this isn't bad this is trump saying hey
i don't want the country panicking so i
am going to do what i need to prevent
the country from panicking because panic
would be bad
that's not what this is donald trump has
no problem with the country panicking
when it is politically advantageous now
there's other clips here um in this next
clip
trump is talking to bob woodward again
and donald trump
uh continues to uh acknowledge
that the virus is airborne and it's far
more dangerous than donald trump ever
admitted
and so what was president xi
saying yesterday well we were talking
mostly about the uh
the virus and i think he's going to have
it in good shape but
you know it's a very tricky situation
it's uh
it goes it goes through air bob that's
always tougher than the touch you know
the touch you don't have to touch things
right but the air
you just breathe the air and that's how
it's uh passed
and so that's a very tricky one that's a
very delicate one
it's also more deadly than your you know
your even your strenuous flus you know
people don't realize we lose 25 000 30
000 people a year here
who would ever think that right i know
that's pretty amazing
and then i say well is that the same
thing for
this is more deadly this is five per
you know this is five percent versus one
percent and less than one percent
you know so this is deadly stuff now
at the time when trump said this to bob
woodward
publicly trump was saying it's like a
seasonal flu
it's going to disappear 15 cases will
soon be zero
it is a straight-up lie the only debate
is whether the lie was justified for
some reason i think the answer is
clearly no
other interesting things asked by bob
woodward
whether racism is here in the united
states in a way that affects people's
lives donald trump replied i think it is
and i think it's unfortunate but i
believe it is
i don't think there is systematic or
institutional
racism in this country well i think
there is everywhere i think probably
less here than most places or less here
than many places
okay but is it here in a way that it has
an
impact on people's lives i think it is
and it's unfortunate but i think it is
so trump admitting there something that
again he has refused to acknowledge
publicly and overall this is a wild book
all sorts of stunning material from bob
woodward we're going to talk later about
uh the report in this book that donald
trump's former secretary of defense jim
mattis
said to the director of national
intelligence dan coats that they may
need
collective action to remove donald trump
we're going to talk later about whether
bob woodward had a responsibility
to make some of these elements public
sooner than he did
we're going to get to all of that but
the top line the big
story that there are even legal scholars
saying is an impeachable offense
although it's a question mark for me
what do i know but really the top line
is
donald trump knew how serious coronavir
coronavirus was back in february early
february
and he didn't acknowledge it publicly
ostensibly claiming
it's to avoid causing panic but we know
how that worked out tens of millions of
americans to this day
still don't think this is a serious
pandemic because of that early denial
campaign
by donald trump and meanwhile and
tomorrow i'm going to get to this
there's just so much here
meanwhile donald trump's approval
in all likelihood is going to remain
around 45 percent
because something is very wrong with our
country
donald trump is admitting i pretended it
was less serious
which led to more death than necessary
and approval
is not likely to budge very much it's
amazing it's amazing in terms of the
indictment that it is
of our country anybody in my view who
has not left donald trump already
is probably not going to leave him
because of this
but i don't want to get ahead of myself
we're going to get into that tomorrow
now meanwhile
you have and we'll discuss this on the
bonus show today
donald trump is arguing that he should
be considered for the nobel peace prize
and in fact
a far-right norwegian politician has
nominated him for it
on the other hand we are wondering
whether his handling of coronavirus
counts as a crime against humanity
that's how disparate
the country is right now on the issue of
donald trump
now just just one sec i want to go back
again to the explanation that is the
predominant one
in response to this audio which is
donald trump didn't want to cause panic
that's a good reason
to downplay the virus that is barely
better even if you believe it
i don't believe it because donald trump
has no problem causing panic as i said
when he judges it's politically
advantageous
immigrant caravan anarchists in the
streets
joe biden's america you'll have a
depression like you've never seen before
trump is fine causing panic when it's
good for him
but imagine that it is true that donald
trump didn't want to panic americans
we had more death than we needed because
americans weren't panicked in other
words
americans panicking or what i call
taking it more seriously
would have saved lives and the next few
weeks could see
all sorts of tapes coming out there may
be more bob woodward tapes
michael cohen may have tapes there are
all sorts of tapes that could be
floating around but again
really will it matter tomorrow on the
program i will argue
no and we will get to that but
first let's talk about some of the other
allegations
in bob woodward's book one of the most
stunning revelations from bob woodward's
new book rage is that donald trump's
former secretary of defense jim mattis
went to the director of national
intelligence dan coats
and said dan the time may come
where we need collective action on
donald trump
which by every reasonable interpretation
that is code 4 the cabinet may have to
come together
and use the 25th amendment to remove
donald trump
bob woodward's book also alleging that
jim mattis
saw donald trump as quote dangerous and
quote
unfit and in a separate conversation
recounted by bob woodward jim mattis
reportedly said to the
dni dan coats quote the president has no
moral compass
to which dan coats replied true to him
a lie is not a lie it's just what he
thinks
he doesn't know the difference between
the truth and a lie
so let's kind of dig into this at the
big picture level
i'm guessing most of my audience
understands it's not normal
it's not typical for multiple
high-ranking individuals
like the secretary of defense and the
director of national intelligence
to be talking together about hey we
might at some point need to act to
remove the president
because he is unfit and he cannot lead
that is not typical that did not happen
during barack obama it didn't happen
during george w
bush although certainly george w bush
did a lot of things that were
absolutely atrocious and and and
disgusting
this is not normal now what do they mean
when they say collective action
by every stretch of of my imagination
it can mean one thing and one thing only
which is the potential use of the 25th
amendment to remove
a president now the 25th amendment it's
you know
available this is a public document as
you as you know
um it has four articles in it the first
three
refer to other circumstances where a
president would have to be replaced for
example
if the president is incapacitated for
for some reason or if a president were
to die
the fourth article of the 25th amendment
is the relevant one here and thinking
about what jim mattis was talking about
and
that fourth article of the 25th
amendment says
that the vice president and cabinet
officials can vote on the removal of a
president
if the majority votes for removal
meaning
the vp plus the cabinet a letter
goes to the leader the senate uh pro
temp and the speaker of the house
telling them we have voted to remove the
president the president is then able to
respond if the president disagrees with
his removal or her removal in this case
his removal
the president can write a letter to the
senate in the house saying i am fit to
serve
and then both houses of congress would
have to vote now
in the meantime if the vice president
sends a letter
saying i agree that the president is
unfit
until the house and senate vote the vice
president
becomes acting president of the united
states it's sticky and it's sloppy and
it's convoluted
but the point here is jim mattis the
then
secretary of defense brought this to the
director of national intelligence and
said
we may need to do this we may need
collective action
that alone is one of the biggest
scandals of the last many decades
the fact that this was a conversation
that took place at the highest levels is
completely outrageous and out of this
world a scandal
if the world made sense donald trump
would have already resigned based on
everything that well actually
if the world made sense donald trump
never would have been elected
given that he was if the world made
sense
the countless scandals that donald trump
has been involved in
would have led to a resignation long ago
the world does not make sense
and instead we are faced with a very
real prospect not of donald trump's
removal
but of donald trump being awarded
another four years and fascinatingly
that there are trumpists
who heard this news that jim mattis was
thinking
we may actually have to remove this guy
and some of those trumpists reacted by
saying i told you the military was
planning a coup
against donald trump now of course
mattis is gone
mattis was talking about this in his
role as a member of the cabinet
happening to be secretary of defense
this was not a military action that was
being considered
it's a cabinet action but the fact that
they will excuse
anything they will find a way to say
donald trump is the victim here
donald billionaire guy born with a spoon
in his mouth
has become in the eyes of many of his
followers and in his own eyes
the biggest victim the most poorly
treated man on earth you would have he
would have you believe
um it is truly amazing and again i don't
want to get ahead of myself but
i'm putting together my thoughts um i
don't think this is going to have
any impact on donald trump and we'll
deal with that tomorrow
in the meantime what is your reaction to
these audio leaks do you think they will
have any bearing whatsoever on the
upcoming election
let me know on twitter where you can
find me
at d pacman d-p-a-k-m-a-n
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about 200
but it'll look like you spent a lot more
all of their watches are made in small
batches from
top quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that uh this is a program that
really wouldn't exist without your
support and the primary
source of that support comes through
website memberships you can read
all about it and sign up in under a
minute at
joinpacman.com we do have a really great
discussion forum with more than i think
we're close to 22 or 23
000 of our viewers are subscribed to our
subreddit you can find it at
davidpakman.com
reddit there are a number of interesting
posts from our viewers a couple of which
i want to highlight
um one user who goes by the uh
name stressed matt said would the
cutting of the postal service hurt
republicans
we know that democrats are more likely
to vote absentee while republicans are
more likely to vote in person but
republicans are more likely to live in
rural areas rural areas are the
ones are the areas that actually need a
functioning postal service the most
so given the delays would it be more
likely for a rural voter to not have
their ballot delivered on time
compared to someone in a city well you
have to compare that which i'm sure
you're right about you have to compare
that to
the disproportionate number of biden
supporters planning to vote by mail and
that already accounts for the urban
rural divide so it's it's ultimately a
math problem
my instinct my instinct is
that still accounting for the urban
rural divide
it is still joe biden who's worse off if
the postal service
fails to deliver um absentee ballot
that's my instinct
uh but ultimately it is an empirical
question
with some unknowns and we'd have to
think about whether we can actually
gather all the data we need to answer
that another post
from the subreddit by user kmlo17
who says can we all just take a moment
to recognize the fact
that david is now less than ten thousand
subscribers
shy of one million uh it is not even ten
thousand
in fact let me take a look while we're
while we're talking here
we are now only seven thousand
subscribers shy
of one million on youtube it's actually
looking like we're going to hit the
million during our vacation week which
you know if five years ago you said uh
you're going to hit a million
subscribers in 2020 but you'll be on
vacation
i would have said there's no way you
could know that and it does look like
that's the way it's going to be
but we've got some great videos and a
bunch of great congratulatory messages
from
some of our friends many of whom you
will recognize plan for when we do hit 1
million subscribers so yes we are only
7 000 subscribers away help us
once we get to a million i think things
are going to get very very crazy
in in a number of different ways
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
and of course
join the discussion on the david pakman
show subreddit
at davidpakman.com r-e-d-d-i-t
okay let's dig into this bob woodward
holding the tapes for too long
discussion that's happening earlier in
the show i told you about the audio
taped revelations that were released
yesterday by journalist bob woodward
this is sort of part of his
uh new book release rage where he cites
a lot of these recorded conversations in
the book he also has
released many of those audio tapes and
they are shocking
donald trump knew in february that the
coronavirus was far more dangerous
than he's ever really admitted but he
was certainly downplaying it during
february
publicly saying we've got five cases
we've got 15 it will soon be zero while
privately as he said to bob woodward on
february 7th and around that time
this is very serious trump at the time
thought it was airborne trump thought it
was hitting more than just people who
were
older or sicker it is outrageous people
died as a result of how donald trump
handled this publicly many people
there's no question about it
bob woodward's investigative reporting
continues to break news
he's had an incredible career no
question
about that but the question that is
being asked is
if bob woodward had gone public with
that information months ago
instead of now to sell a book could
lives have been saved
in other words knowing in march
that donald trump was still publicly
downplaying the virus
and knowing that in february privately
he had acknowledged how dangerous it was
should bob woodward have said i've got
to release these audio tapes now
because it could save lives and indeed
there is a ton of blowback against bob
woodward now
arguing exactly that that he should have
blown the whistle and he should have
said listen
trump is saying something publicly i
have him on tape
saying something very different
privately some examples
john stanton the former washington
bureau chief for buzzfeed tweeted quote
there is no ethical or moral defense of
woodward's decision
to not publish these tapes as soon as
they were made if there was
any chance it could save a single life
he was obligated to do so
bob woodward put making money over his
moral and professional
duty jessica huseman a reporter for
propublica tweeted
similarly quote how differently might
trump supporters have acted if this
whole time
they knew that he knew covid was a
serious threat woodward could have made
that happen in february
jose antonio vargas a filmmaker and
former reporter for the washington post
tweeted quote
if journalism is a public trust a trust
that has consistently eroded
and bob woodward is an associate editor
at the washington post
why did woodward sit on this information
while americans
suffered and died now bob woodward was
asked
about that exact decision in a brief
interview he did with the associated
press and bob woodward's reaction was he
needed time to ensure
that donald trump's remarks were
accurate now
that sounds weird to me it's weird to me
that
for months bob woodward needed to
confirm
that coronavirus really was deadly as
donald trump told him it was on february
7th that's weird
but what would be a better
counter-argument there are a few
let's examine them david moranis who's
an investigative journalist
and an associate editor at the
washington post tweeted quote
i agree completely and i'm puzzled by
some of the short-sighted thinking on
this by people with whom i often agree
the argument that lives might have been
saved had bob reported this earlier is a
historical the tapes are an invaluable
public service
another argument this is eric wemple a
washington post media critic who said
quote
if trump thought woodward i'm sorry no
this is not part of the quote eric
wemple makes the argument
that quote seeing a lot of arguments
that bob woodward did something
unethical or untoward
in holding on to his scoop about trump's
admission
that he played down the coronavirus i
disagree with the criticism
woodward is a book author and the
implicit understanding with his sources
is that he'll interview them interview
them again and again and again until he
can
stitch together something authoritative
in book form
so where do i come down on this i
believe that the strongest
counter-argument is that it is very
plausible that donald trump never would
have been
interviewed by bob woodward in other
words he never would have accepted
sitting down with bob woodward if he had
known
that bob woodward was going to publish
some of this stuff right away
i think that that's a realistic thing if
bob woodward
says i want to interview you but i might
just publish this stuff next week
trump probably refuses the interview the
pretext of accepting the interview
likely included um the
the belief that this would not be
published until it came out in a book
months later
now bob woodward could have made the
decision even though my intent was not
to publish this stuff right away
this is of such public health importance
this is of such national importance
that i have to go public with this
that's something that bob woodward
could have done the question then
becomes would it
actually have saved lives i don't know
that it would have
now let me walk you through my thinking
it seems obvious
if donald trump had publicly taken the
virus seriously
starting in february rather than denying
its seriousness
a lot of his followers would have taken
it more seriously
and thus fewer people would have died
that i think is true
the problem is what we're talking about
is not
trump publicly taking it more seriously
what we're talking about
is in march for example bob woodward
blowing the whistle and saying hey
trump's lying
i have him on tape i caught him
red-handed i don't believe that would
have made a difference to trump's
followers and why don't i believe that
because it hasn't made a difference so
far
trump has gotten caught red-handed doing
everything you can imagine and his
supporters by and large
have not punished him nothing happens
now we'll see in just over seven weeks
whether in total
trump is held accountable for this
disastrous four years
but i have a hard time imagining that
even if bob woodward did go public
in march with this saying whoa whoa whoa
hold on a second stop the clock
i have audio trump knows this is serious
trump would come out and just insult
everybody
kaylee magananny would have come out and
done a press briefing and come up with
some rationale for why this is not a big
deal
and then people would have moved on to
the next scandal sort of how
we are now moving on to this one from
dead soldiers or suckers and losers from
just a few days ago
so if i were bob woodward me personally
i would have come forward because i
would want to clear my own conscience
that's me do i think it would have made
a substantive difference
i have a hard time thinking it would
have because it would be just like when
any journalist comes out with anything
about donald trump
his followers either don't believe it or
ignore it
or write it off or whatever so
if it were me i would have come come
public because of my own conscience i
don't know that it really would have
made a difference
we're going to explore this in more
detail on the david pakman show
instagram i hope you were following us
there at david pakman show we're going
to take a quick break
and next i am going to dive into some
new policy proposals from joe biden
we will look at a very strange interview
that donald trump gave to sean hannity
last night and so much more
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's important to keep an eye on joe
biden's policy proposals because on the
one hand you have donald trump holding
huge rallies as if there's no pandemic
while insulting joe biden saying joe
biden is stupid as he did earlier this
week
and then on the other hand as a contra
contrast you have joe biden
actually proposing some pretty
interesting policies and one such policy
that joe biden
recently released is a 10 tax penalty
on companies that move operations
overseas and then on the other side of
that a 10
tax credit for companies that create
jobs in the united states
i like the idea of joe biden rolling out
more economic policies because
if you're someone who's voting on the
big picture right you
you realize donald trump is a completely
incompetent systemic threat to the
united states and the world
and he's made the country a global
laughing stock you may already be clear
on
i'm voting biden in november there are
people who for one reason or another
need
some more specific economic
justifications to vote for joe biden and
one of those
is that joe biden says he will reverse
some of the worst policies of the trump
administration which he believes are
loopholes that allow offshoring to take
place
despite donald trump claiming his entire
campaign
and during his presidency that he would
be and has been great for the
american worker and for american
business it's impossible to ignore
the reality that joe biden on some of
these issues
is saying he will achieve the exact same
thing donald trump promised to achieve
when he was campaigning
which is joe biden much like donald
trump said in 2015
says he will revive american
manufacturing joe biden
much like donald trump campaigned on in
2016 says he will create
more american jobs and bring some supply
chains back to the united states
of course you will notice that the
reason joe biden
is saying he will do those same things
is donald trump promised to do them but
failed
to do so and joe biden's new proposal
will target offshore profits now
and then this is going to bigger picture
get added
into his plan to require corporations to
pay at least a 15 percent
minimum tax on domestic profits as many
of you know
even though we have a corporate tax rate
here in the united states with no
required minimum tax on corporations the
way individuals have there's something
called the alternative minimum tax
for individuals meaning you can't use
deductions and loopholes
to get down to not owing anything that
in theory that's the point of the
alternative minimum tax joe biden is
proposing
something similar for corporations on
the other side of this
is you've got on one side a 10 tax for
offshoring
and then you have a 10 percent made in
america tax credit which you would
qualify for
if you as a business owner revitalize a
closed or almost closed facility in the
united states
if you expand a facility if you bring
some production back to the united
states and there will also be a ten
percent credit available
if you increase manufacturing wages you
it has to be based on pre-coronavirus as
a baseline
up to a hundred thousand dollars this is
super interesting let me give you an
example of how it works
you could conceivably have an employee
earning fifty thousand dollars
and you could say i'm going to give them
a raise to sixty thousand dollars
on that ten thousand dollar raise
biden's proposal is
the government will kick you back ten
percent of it so you give a ten thousand
dollar raise
the government gives you a thousand
dollar tax credit so you give someone
ten thousand dollars it only costs you
nine that's
very very interesting and you know the
macro economic impact
needs to be scored uh but conceptually
it's very interesting
now i i wonder how many of you are
waiting to see whether i will do this
i would be a hypocrite if i didn't point
this out
when joe biden says it because i sure as
hell pointed it out when donald trump
said it
all of the talk about bringing
manufacturing jobs back to the united
states
a lot of these jobs are not coming back
period it doesn't matter if donald trump
is president
it doesn't matter if joe biden is
president and you know a 10
credit here a 10 percent tax there it's
not going to do it
and that is because the united states
made the decision implicitly decades ago
that we are going in the direction of
being more of a service-based economy
more of a creative economy and
outsourcing manufacturing to places
where it's cheaper
like china that's the reality and that's
a global reality that's bigger than 10
tax here or 10 credit there now that
being said
if this incentive got american companies
to for example
move a call center back to the united
states that
is much more plausible and i would find
super interesting for for me
one of the biggest customer service
nightmares is when you're trying to deal
with something sensitive for example
banking payroll airline tickets internet
security and
customer service centers are located in
other parts of the country
which is fine other than when you're
dealing with
people that do not speak english at a
certain level of proficiency
that really affects customer service and
when you look at internet service
providers that offshore call centers
when you look at airlines and all of
these others consistently
it destroys the customer experience
we've had recent internet problems
our internet service providers tech
support is in another part of the world
run by mediocre english speakers they're
not bad people they're no worse than
americans
but it is not a great customer service
experience at one point the payroll
company we used to have
had customer service overseas it's not a
great experience
to be trying to set up you know the
proper tax deductions for employees and
to have someone where you don't even
know if their english
level is at a level of proficiency where
they're getting what you're trying to do
if this idea gets call centers back in
the united states
that would be super interesting and it
would be really good for a lot of
companies
in any case we're going to continue
tracking joe biden's proposals
this is an interesting one meanwhile
donald trump is doing rallies and
calling joe biden stupid
you decide which approach you prefer i
know which one i prefer
sometimes when donald trump does
something we call it humiliating but
it's only humiliating if you have a
certain sensibility
it's only humiliating if you have a
certain worldview donald trump last
night
gave an interview to fox news sean
hannity that was so cringe-worthy
so disgusting that the humiliation
has spread much farther than you can
imagine sean hannity actually brought up
the story of donald trump allegedly
calling
dead soldiers who died in combat suckers
and
losers and donald trump focused in on
the idea
that it's not true that he didn't want
to be out in the reign in france and
that that's part of why donald trump
didn't go
that donald trump says i've been out in
the rain many times
and my hair gets wet and it's no big
deal this
is the level of discussion that is
happening with the president
uh of the united states on one of the
top-rated cable news shows we have a
raging pandemic with nearly 200 000
deaths
we have all sorts of economic problems
we are on the precipice of a major
election and donald trump is on cable
news saying
it's okay if my hair gets wet i made a
speech in the rain
no umbrellas know anything you know they
said it's just this information i didn't
want to get my hair wet i've had my hair
wet plenty of times
i made plenty of speeches in the rain
and if i wasn't
if i didn't you wouldn't be president
right now that i can tell you so
it's disinformation they made up a story
about two disgusting words that they say
i said
and i didn't and i have many witnesses
we have 21 witnesses they only have
sources
of course trump doesn't seem to realize
that a witness to something saying
you didn't say it is a weird thing if
someone comes forward and says
i didn't hear trump say it that's not
proof it wasn't said
all it means is you didn't hear it and
it's it's very difficult of course to
prove a negative that's by
by its very nature hard to do donald
trump doesn't seem to get that and he
insists listen
zach said some guy named zach zack said
i didn't say it well that just means he
didn't hear you say it
earlier this week i reported to you that
donald trump's campaign
is tight on cash they have had to slow
down ad spending
in some key states the fundraising is a
problem
and sean hannity this is i mean this is
how you turn manure into gold or at
least
attempt to sean hannity hilariously
asked donald trump
is not buying ads a strategy like is not
having money maybe a strategy even check
this out
say that is not the case yeah a little
shy at 300 million dollars but
i was told by a friend in florida that
that joe biden has
three to one ads running against yours
is this a strategy you're waiting or
is this something that you didn't want
maybe you're just ramping up after labor
day
so four years ago i won it in the last
month
and we have about three times more cash
now than we had then and that's without
me putting up any of i needed extra i'll
put it up myself i just
i said that two days ago i said if
there's any necessary
extra cash but we have a lot of money
coming in and small donors i haven't
been heavy on big donors because i don't
want to call them you know when you call
big donors you
you sort of put yourself in a very
compromising position
trump knows how compromising it is
to get money from donors because he
spent the last four years doing favors
to his donors
uh and it's very interesting to hear
donald trump say
we won it in the last month in 2016.
this is not a guarantee of anything of
course
joe biden's lead today today is 7.5
nationally hillary's lead on this day in
2016
was 2.7 so today joe biden's lead is
nearly three times as large as hillary's
was at this time in 2016.
it doesn't mean trump is going to lose
but trump
saying this year is just like 2016
is uh assuming a lot in 2016 donald
trump was not already the president
in 2016 donald trump was much closer
uh to his opponent than where he is
today that that those are just
factual differences then donald trump
goes on to say
that right now the united states has
a record number of jobs what that means
is a question
you don't know what they're doing
frankly but they should all be open
and our country is doing very well we
have record numbers of jobs you saw the
numbers
just came out for the four months it's
the largest number
ever by far not even close so we do not
have a record number of jobs right now
donald trump has no idea what he's
talking about remember that
the big picture numbers are we lost
close to 50 million jobs during the
pandemic
many of those have come back okay but
we are still way down the idea that we
have more jobs than ever is something
that you have a tough time convincing a
12 year old of
even a smart nine-year-old probably
wouldn't fall for it but donald trump
throws out this generality we have the
record number of jobs it's very much
untrue
you're not going to hear any fact
checking of it from sean hannity
and then also continuing to spread what
at this point is just embarrassing
disinformation
donald trump claiming that if you look
at our coronavirus numbers
that they're actually amazing it's just
incredible how well we've done
it's two million two and a half million
maybe even more than that if we did it a
different way and
we've done a really good job but if you
look at our numbers our fatality numbers
compared to
other countries we're in we're in
really i mean it's amazing what we've
done we've been able to do something
that
a country especially with the kind of
size we're dealing with
we've done an incredible job the truth
there of course
is our numbers are really really bad
now if you don't adjust for our
population
the u.s has by far the most coronavirus
deaths but we also have a lot of people
we really need to be looking at per
capita numbers
on a per capita basis the united states
is 11th highest in the world out of more
than 200 countries and territories
in terms of deaths per capita now if you
take out
some of these tiny countries and
territories which can skew the numbers
like
san marino and andorra the united states
has the ninth highest deaths per capita
from coronavirus in the world it's not
the lowest
it's not in the bottom half it is the
ninth highest
in the world question to you when trump
says this stuff
when trump says we have more jobs than
ever when trump says
we have the best coronavirus numbers in
the world do people believe it
are there people who hear trump say it
and think trump's right
we've done such a great job we're so
much better off than every other country
or is it just something he has to say
even if no one is going to believe it i
actually don't know the answer
i know there are people who do think
we're doing well on the virus
but i don't know that they think it
because donald trump is the one saying
it let me know your thoughts
and bigger picture does an interview
like this do trump any favors
is this a net gain for trump in some way
to be interviewed by sean hannity even
if he makes no sense
in ways that i can't exactly understand
does this do damage
or does it really not make a difference
whatsoever if you look at the the sort
of
framework of alan lichtman who predicts
elections using a qualitative rather
than quantitative system
he would argue i think that this doesn't
matter that really what impacts the
election
are big issues what is the status of the
economy
is there a major calamity etc there are
others
who may have a different perspective let
me know in general
do interviews like this have any impact
on the election results we would expect
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
the david pakman show at david
davidpakman.com
so when a couple of months ago we got
these really wild polls nationally
polls that had donald trump down to joe
biden by 10 points nationally by 12
points nationally there were even a few
that said donald trump was down by 15
points nationally
i said at the time whether or not
those polls were accurate at the time
and remember accurate means within the
margin of error so if it says 15 it
could really be eight uh depending on
the margin of error
i repeated at the time it is very
unlikely
that on election day we're going to see
a 10 point margin
in the popular vote it's just
extraordinarily unlikely
i i don't think any of us should be
imagining that that's the case we should
imagine it's going to be much tighter
and it means we all have to vote
at the same time if these polls keep
coming out we can't really ignore them
and indeed there are now multiple new
polls that have joe biden up by 12.
there is a new reuters ipsos poll which
says that joe biden leads donald trump
by 12 points nationally
that's among likely voters 52 to 40.
there's also a new
usc poll which says joe biden is up by
12 and
importantly in that one joe biden is
polling at 53
so in both the reuters ipsos poll and
the usc poll
not only is donald trump losing by
double digits but joe biden is over 50
support which is an important metric to
keep an eye on now in these
polls somewhere between three and five
percent of likely voters say they're
just undecided right now
now i've talked about this before who
are those people
how could you possibly be undecided at
this point unless you've literally not
paid attention to politics and in that
case
how likely are you to actually vote
that's a question if we
say the electorate is expected to be
about 130 million people
if five percent are undecided um
that is six and a half million voters
right now six and a half million voters
who are looking at this situation and
saying
i might vote biden or i might vote trump
i continue to be stunned and appalled by
that reality i would love to talk to
some of those undecided voters i invite
you to call in
i've not heard from any of them so far
now it's really important to remember
that a popular vote margin correlates
differently to the likelihood of an
electoral victory for democrats versus
republicans there is a
structural imbalance against democrats
where as you know
sometimes democrats win the popular vote
and don't become president because they
lose the electoral college as
i'm sure you remember unless you're four
years old in which case
i don't even know that we have
four-year-olds in our audience in 2016
donald trump lost the popular vote by
2.1
but he won the electoral college thanks
to 70-something
thousand votes in three states nate
silver
from 538 did something important he
crunched the numbers to tell us
given a particular popular vote margin
how likely is it that joe biden will win
the electoral college
and again understand that the numbers
are skewed in this way
because of the urban rural divide and
because of some other
sort of base level factors that favor
republicans in the electoral college
uh even at the even while
being at a disadvantage in the popular
vote so
if joe biden wins the popular vote by
under one point his odds of becoming
president of getting 270 electoral votes
are only six percent if joe biden can
win
the popular vote by one to two points
he has a 22 percent chance of winning
the electoral college
if joe biden matches hillary clinton's
popular vote win
somewhere in the two to three point
range it is still
slightly more likely that trump wins the
electoral college in other words if
biden gets
a similar margin of victory in the
popular vote to hillary
he only has a 46 chance of winning the
electoral college
that's why we all have to vote only when
joe biden's popular vote lead
gets beyond three points does joe biden
become the likely candidate to become
president if he wins
between three and four points in the
popular vote he has a 74
chance of being president and as you can
see if joe biden
were to get a six point popular vote win
the odds of becoming president go above
99
if in some other universe joe biden
actually were to win the popular vote by
10
um it would be all but certain that he
becomes the next president of the united
states so
that's how i would be thinking about the
popular vote
versus the electoral vote scenario now
let's look at joe biden's average lead
right now because
the 12 point lead is not representative
of the average if you look at joe
biden's
average in all national polls he's up by
6.9
okay if joe biden were to win by 6.9 as
i just showed you
he will almost certainly win the
electoral college right
well yes and no if he really wins by 6.9
yes
but remember that there is a margin of
error here
now when you're averaging poll results
you can't just say okay biden's up by
6.9
if the average poll has a 3 margin of
error for each candidate that means
maybe joe's only up by 0.9
there are some complex mathematics
involved
in figuring out an overall margin of
error
when you're already averaging poll
results which
in and of themselves have margins of
error it doesn't matter
the point is uh hillary clinton
ended up with a popular vote win that
was
two-thirds the size of what the polling
predicted so let me put it a different
way
hillary clinton was expected to win by
three in the polls
she won by two that means her real
margin was
two-thirds of the expected margin
if we apply that to joe biden if we say
okay
biden is winning by 6.9
but we're only expecting him to win by
two-thirds of that
that would be about a four-point popular
vote margin of victory if that were the
case
it still doesn't guarantee victory for
joe biden
but it certainly starts to look pretty
good what does this mean
this means we all have to vote that's
really all that this means and
uh even though the popular vote numbers
may be looking pretty good
we do have to talk about something
that's going on in minnesota which is
not looking quite so good
so on this program i try to strike the
right balance between being complacent
and being alarmist i try to avoid being
either i try to just be realistic and
kind of give it to you straight
simply telling you that there is concern
among democrats about minnesota
i think is accurate i don't think it's
alarmist and i don't think it's
complacent
donald trump according to some
democratic strategists
could win the state of minnesota and you
might be worried
you might be wondering minnesota or
should we really be worried about that
why
well the truth is that minnesota hasn't
voted for a republican presidential
candidate
since 1972 that's just shy of 50 years
ago
and if you look at the polling it sort
of looks okay right i mean it looks okay
for joe biden
joe biden's currently leading the
polling in minnesota by an average of
3.7
but the problem is that 3.7
really isn't that much to be comfortable
with minnesota
was actually already almost a problem
for hillary clinton in 2016 hillary
clinton did win minnesota in 2016
but only by about 1.5 and if you look
further into history
barack obama won minnesota by 11.
uh in 2008 he won it by eight in 2012.
john kerry won minnesota by four in 2004
al gore won it only by two in the year
2000 and so
when you see it this close and you know
that there's voter suppression that's
not in the polling there's meddling
that's not in the polling there's all
sorts of things that are not reflected
by the polling
i am not particularly comfortable with
joe biden being up by only 3.7
in the state of minnesota now there's
another reason that minnesota
could be a problem and minnesota could
turn into
the wisconsin of 2020. remember in 2016
hillary clinton was widely criticized
for not
spending time in wisconsin a state that
she ultimately lost by a very small
margin
and it was one of those three states
that flipped the results
to donald trump electorally joe biden
may have a similar situation
right now and what i mean by that is in
florida
joe biden is struggling with latino
voters right now in florida
and it seems as though joe biden is
going to have to devote
even more resources to florida florida
always a focal point particularly for
democrats because
taking florida away from the republican
candidate is so
powerful in these electoral races to 270
but again if joe biden has to put more
time and effort into florida than he
would
otherwise have to ordinarily have to
were it not for the hispanic vote
uh he may not have the resources or time
in minnesota
and minnesota is exactly the type of
state that the polling could get wrong
remember
the 2016 polling was mostly correct at
the national level
at the national level the polling said
hillary's up three
and she won by more than two in the
popular vote but it is also true
that the polling was not correct in
wisconsin in wisconsin
hillary clinton in the polling was
winning by six and a half
and you might recall as i just mentioned
five minutes ago donald trump
won wisconsin by about three quarters of
a point the wisconsin polling was very
very wrong
so what do we do about minnesota about
all of these
situations well we learn from the past
we learn from past experiences
we understand that democrats are worried
about minnesota and so we should be
worried about minnesota and we should
focus on it
when trump advisors what let me back up
when trump publicly says all our polls
look great we're winning everything
it's bs we all know it's bs when
privately trump advisers and republican
strategists say
we're not writing off michigan we
understand
that michigan could get complicated when
privately
they start looking again at a state like
minnesota
we understand that we can't ignore it we
never
stop the focus on getting out the vote
and
any one of these states could be the
difference maker now in the coming weeks
i'm going to show you some of my
plausible
electoral maps now why the hell would
you listen to me about that
you really shouldn't i got it way wrong
in uh in 2016.
in 2016 i believed the wisconsin polling
and so on my map i had wisconsin
definitely for hillary
i was wrong uh but i am going to give
you
some scenarios and incredibly there is a
scenario for
for this upcoming election that would
put the electoral votes
at 269 to 269. it's
not the most likely scenario but it's
also not that unlikely
and it depends on maine being split as
they do
in terms of their electoral vote so we
will get to that
we have plenty of time for that we have
a voicemail number which is 2192 david p
i invite you yes you to call anytime
if you want to call it four in the
morning as many people do
go ahead and call it four in the morning
or call at a more normal time
here is a voicemail asking really a
pretty important question
about what will republicans do about
trump if trump loses in november hey
david
i feel like we don't talk enough about
how if trump loses he's going to be
tweeting
from the sidelines constantly and i'm
serious your thoughts if you think
his base will still hold him up as a god
if you think um
members of congress will um uh be
influenced by him or if they're just
gonna if they're eager to just
have an excuse to ignore him i'm curious
your thoughts thank you
i think it is ultimately going to depend
it's a good question if trump
loses but he just keeps tweeting
tweeting tweeting and he has a presence
and he's on fox news
what will actual elected republicans do
will they still sort of uh
give deference to trump and listen to
trump or will they
um denounce him i think it will likely
be neither i think the most likely
scenario is
if donald trump loses and ultimately he
will go he will resist it he will claim
it's rigged but ultimately he will go
my sense is yes donald trump will keep
tweeting yes donald trump will continue
to be interviewed
on maybe it'll be fox news maybe he'll
shift to oan maybe he will start his own
uh right wing network of some kind my
instinct is republicans will not widely
denounce trump
but they'll sort of pretend it never
happened remember how uh george w
bush was not a big part at all
of john mccain's 2008 campaign because
george w bush was very unpopular
and polarizing donald trump is 10 times
more than that
so my expectation would be that there
would be a lot of sort of pretending the
last four years didn't happen
if donald trump loses um and i do not
see it as likely that trump
will shut up i think that he will
continue to use twitter and platforms
because he's narcissistic and he's
desperate for attention all the time
we have a great bonus show for you today
i will tell you and pat will tell you
what we have planned for our upcoming
staff vacation we are going to be on
vacation next week the show is not being
canceled
we are going to be back more powerfully
than ever probably with a million
youtube subscribers after that vacation
but we are taking next week off we will
talk about what we're going to do
we will talk about this totally bogus
nomination trump received from a
far-right norwegian politician for the
nobel peace prize
we will talk about the astrazeneca
vaccine trial
being paused and some people are making
a way bigger deal out of this than it
actually is so we're going to talk about
that
and also very interesting news from the
field of
is it archaeology uh egyptian
authorities discovered
13 completely sealed 2500 year old
coffins
super interesting news we will talk
about the implications
and much more on today's bonus show how
do you get access to the bonus show it's
easy
it's really really easy you go to
joinpakman.com
that's www.joinpacman.com
and you sign up that's it it takes under
a minute and you can use the coupon code
this is 2020 to save
66 off of your membership actually no
i'm sorry
this is 2020 saves you 40 it's still
good
if you want to save 66 the coupon code
is
2020 now 2020 now i will see you on the
bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches but
making them affordable for everyday
people and they're giving you 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero
today's show also sponsored by blinkist
blinkist is the app that lets you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free and get 25 off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put that link down
below
underneath the video